[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday October
4th and today's video comes in four
parts part 1 stuff on your heads Hank
I'm totally in favor of the stuff on
your heads idea in fact it seems to me
that this is one of the last great areas
for human exploration I mean Hank there
are so many things that can go on a
person's head and yet so few of them
have actually been recorded being on
someone's head and that seems to me a
grave injustice part 2 the happy dance
project Hank after your great song
yesterday you said that you wanted me to
talk about the happy dance project today
but I don't really have that much to say
about the happy dance project I mean
I'll tell you one thing we got a lot of
happy dances incidentally if any
nerdfighters want to send us a happy
dance video late they're welcome to do
so although we can no longer 100%
guarantee that it will be part of the
happy dance project but we'd like to see
it nonetheless
Hank having watched a lot of happy dance
videos now I can make one observation
about happy dances which is this they
tend to be either arm centric or leg
centric like your happy dance is
definitely arm centric it's like that or
whatever and then my happy dance is very
leg centric it's all about like kicking
my knees up I've noticed that not very
many nerdfighters have torso centric
happy dances and I think that might be
related to our general inability to you
know bust a move
anyway Hank I don't want to build up
expectations too much but when it
finally does happen the happy dance
project is going to be pretty nerd
tastic part 3 raccoons Hank it's no
secret how I feel about outside my
relationship with outside is like a
healthy relationship with an
ex-girlfriend I want the best for
outside when good things happen to
outside I'm happy and when outside
suffers some misfortune I feel sorry for
outside I even enjoy spending time with
outside on occasion but I do think that
there need to be boundaries and one of
those boundaries Hank is that outside is
not allowed inside my home which is why
I am very unhappy to tell you that I
think that there are raccoons in my
attic and when I say I think I mean I
know but I'm not yet willing to admit
anyway Hank I've been in touch with some
professionals on this issue and I will
keep you up-to-date on the great raccoon
hunt of 2007 part 4 feud Hank I'd like
to suggest some topics about which we
could potentially feud here are some
topics and my opinions on them dragons
or fairies dragons love or money love I
mean like you're gonna pick money
actually you might pick money god you
love money
returned ninjas ninjas Hank I know that
everyone in comments was like pirates
pone but seriously pirates pirates
haven't been cool since Goonies I mean
it's one of the best online video series
in history called ask a pirate green
apples are red apples actually on that
one I'm for Fiona apples anybody puns
puns no no puns okay lakes or rivers
rivers and honestly I don't even want to
be your brother anymore if you're not
for rivers I mean who's against rivers
it's like being against puppies speaking
of which puppies are kittens puppies
although I have nothing against kittens
they're adorable
mary-kate versus Ashley the one that
doesn't have a cocaine problem I guess
books versus movies books texts vs.
video texts unicorns versus zombies
zombies although I'm profoundly troubled
by both Hank if none of those few topics
work perhaps you can suggest some more
I'm off to New York for the weekend go
Cubs I'll see you tomorrow oh and Hank
don't forget to be awesome